-That's exactly what I'm talking about.
Chris Evans, welcome. -How are you, buddy?
[ Cheers and applause ] -That's got to feel good.
-Yeah. Yeah, every time. -Welcome back to the show.
-Thanks, man. -It is always great to see you.
You've been such a good friend to the show.
Since I've last seen you, though,
some major thing happened. I don't know if you saw this.
You were named Sexiest Man Alive.
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's right, that's right. That's right.
-You all right? You know what I'm saying?
-That's right, that's right. -Yeah.
You put, "Thanks, People.
I think we can all agree that it's damn near impossible
to follow in Paul Rudd's footsteps in any capacity,
but I'll do my best." -Which is true.
I mean, pretty much in any capacity,
it's tough to follow him, isn't it?
-Yeah. Did you hear anything from Paul Rudd since, uh...
-Yeah, I'm -- Actually, I'm in a fantasy football league
with Paul and a few other actor buddies.
So they haze you, and it almost feels like
that's all that title does is give you a hard time, you know?
Yeah, nobody on the street's like, "Hey. You know what?
You did it." [ Laughter ]
-"Congratulations." Yeah. No, everyone's like...
-No, they're just -- They're just busting your balls.
-Yeah, you're like -- Well, that's good.
How did you do on the fantasy football team?
-Well, I didn't do well this year,
but I've won a few times, so I have bragging rights.
-All right. Yeah. Yeah. [ Cheering ]
I wanted to ask you this question
because I found this very interesting.
I think that you might --
I have to thank you and give you credit for my first ever --
-I heard this. You -- go, go. This is amazing.
Your producer told me this. -My acting debut,
my television debut... -Was...
-...was "Spin City."
-Which is where I interned in the casting office.
Around the same time? Did I --
-I think you -- -Did I give you your first job?
-Wow! [ Laughter ]
I mean, this is -- I feel like I owe my whole career to you.
-What year was it? I mean, it was '98.
-'98. -'98?!
-I played -- I played -- -You're welcome.
-Wow! [ Laughter and applause ]
Wait. So... -Yeah.
-I mean, for real. I remember I was nervous.
I went in. I read for this role
as a photographer number one or something.
-Yeah. -And I -- And I walked in,
I -- and I didn't do anything that special.
So I'm like, "I'm not gonna get this."
But -- -But you got it.
-You did it. [ Laughter ]
-What can I say? -But how --
I don't understand.
How old were you? What were you doing?
-It was the summer of my junior
going into senior year.
I knew I wanted to act, so I moved to the city.
I got a job interning at a casting office
just to meet agents, you know?
And it was -- -Did that work?
-It did, actually.
It's a humbling experience, though.
I mean, you come into your job on a Monday
after there's -- an audition goes out.
What was -- What was the part you had?
-Photographer number one. -Photographer number one, yeah.
So you show up at your desk -- -Hold your applause.
[ Laughter ] -You got -- you got --
-You remember it. -A stack of envelopes
from all these agents in town. -Headshots and...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. And your boss comes in --
And I don't want to get anybody in trouble,
specifically my old boss, but she --
she would pluck out two or three envelopes,
and I threw the rest in the trash.
She just chucked them. And you were just like,
"Wow. This industry is brutal." -Oh, really?
-It's that brutal, tight?
Because you go, like -- You're just trying to get hired.
I mean, I didn't have an agent. I didn't --
I don't know how I got in there. -Yeah.
Well, you certainly can't get upset at your agent.
That's what it told me. Your agent can be trying,
but, you know, sometimes they end up in the trash.
-Yeah, it's just a pile of stuff.
And then you just saw my headshot,
and you were like... -And I was like,
"This guy's got something."
-You're like, "This guy..."
-I thought it was gonna be your headshot!
-No, no, no! It was like, "This guy should be..."
But do you remember casting any other famous talk-show host?
-No, I -- I -- [ Laughter ]
I just sat in the front room, setting up auditions.
I remember some actors would come in.
I remember seeing Jesse -- young Jesse Eisenberg.
-Yeah? -Young Jim Gaffigan
would come in there a lot. -That's wild.
-But again, these are -- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, this is back in like '98.
-Yeah. I want to talk about your movie, "Ghosted."
It's on Apple TV+. It's a romantic comedy.
You, Ana de Armas. It is like --
-Whoo! -Yeah, exactly.
And you two together. Yeah.
So, the idea is that you guys meet-cute, you go on a date,
and then you think she may have ghosted you?
-Yep. -And then you -- you find her.
She -- She -- -Find her, track her down.
Kind of stalker my way... [ Laughter ]
You know, you have this amazing date.
You have this wonderful experience with someone.
You go home, you tell your family, your friends,
and then you don't hear from her.
She -- She ghosted me.
[ Audience groans, "Oohs" ]
-Yeah. Listen to this reaction. [ Laughter ]
Can you believe this? Yeah, I know.
I was in tears. I go, "What?!"
Not my Chris. [ Laughter ]
But you -- She has actually --
It was like an Apple Tag.
You have, like, a tracker that she takes,
like your jacket or something. -Yeah.
-Your inhaler? -I think it's my inhaler.
It's a lot less cool than my jacket.
-Sorry. -It's my inhaler.
-She has your inhaler, and you go,
"I know where she is." -"I know where she is."
And my family's like, "You should go."
You think -- You know -- he's, you know --
he thinks it's a big grand, romantic gesture,
and he ends up getting -- 'Cause she's a spy,
and he ends up getting caught up in this world of espionage.
-It's super fun. And you go, "Oh, my gosh.
"Two..." plug your ears --
"...really good-looking people in this thing."
And I just loved the whole idea. Have you ever been ghosted?
Do you know what that feels like, Chris?
-You know, that's like the number-one question
I'm getting asked on this press tour. I mean --
-You can say. No one's listening.
-Well, you know -- [ Laughter ]
I don't know. I've probably blocked it out
if it's happened. Have you?
-Be honest. [ Laughter ]
-I'm too old to kind of --
Well, see, I kind of feel the same way.
-Does letters count? I mean --
[ Laughter ]
Texting didn't exist when I was dating, you know?
-Your pen pal just fell off. -Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Ran out of ink, you know? You know?
Yeah. I didn't get a pen -- Exactly.
But, I mean, I'm sure I was.
I mean, there's definitely moments where I go,
"Oh, they they're not into me." -Well, see, what
I say is I'd almost rather be ghosted
because you can tell yourself a story.
Like, maybe they, you know, lost their phone.
If you've had the worst,
which is just kind of a gradual, less and less and less text,
then there's really no confusing what's going on.
-Yeah, it's heartbreaking.
But I will say there's some other cameos
that I don't know if I'm allowed to talk about.
-There are some cameos,
which you're not allowed to talk about,
which I just learned right before we came out.
So... [ Laughter and applause ]
Good thing I didn't say anything.
[ Laughter ]
But they're great cameos.
-But they're really great cameos.
-Yeah, there's some friendly faces.
-Yeah, yeah.
Some faces that you've seen before.
-Yeah. Yeah. -Can I --
Legally, I can say that. -I hate asking people
for cameos. It's such an awful thing to do.
-Oh, I wouldn't know what it's like.
[ Laughter ]
I'm very available. [ Laughter ]
It's -- The people that make the cameos
are super good and super funny. -They're fantastic.
-And they're people that you love and you go --
-And they they showed up. They showed up for me.
We asked. -So now show up for Chris Evans.
Here we go. I want to show a clip.
Here's Chris Evans and Ana de Armas in "Ghosted."
Take a look at this.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
♪♪
[ Electricity crackles, man grunts ]
Unh!
-[Bleep]
♪♪
-Kimberly, you took a picture of me while I was sleeping.
-Not of you! Of us!
-I knew you were a creep!
-I'm not a creep!
-You know who says that a lot?
Creeps!
-Oh! Come on! [ Cheers and applause ]
Chris Evans! "Ghosted" premieres globally
on Apple TV+ this Friday.
Chris and I are doing "The Whisper Challenge"
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody. Come back.